now I'm just saying there really is no
excuse for you not to push that lovely
red subscribe button unless you have a
quirk that specifically forbids you from
doing sir but for the rest of you I
recommend that you get right on that if
you'd like to see more my hero academia
content upload it straight into YouTube
feeds and if not then well yeah hello
and welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today I would like to cast my gaze
upon the Walt of my hero academia once
more but this time specifically to the
mindset of the fan base as well as the
greater pool of Shonen readers and
Watchers which frequently come into
conflict regarding the quote unquote
quality of the series because there is a
pretty crazy divide of opinion on my
hero academia with one sign arguing that
it is a brilliant series worthy of
evolving the format whilst others will
argue that it is either generic
overrated or both porque no los dos and
to be perfectly frank my personal
opinion lands somewhere in the middle so
I'm going to thoroughly annoy both
parties in this discussion my both
agreeing and disagreeing with them and
all of this bonds from a recent video I
did reviewing the heroes rising film
which produced a radically polarizing
response in the comments section with
people either begging me from all my
hero academia content while making their
eternal hatred or at the very least
grand sense of despise for the series
known so I think this is quite an
interesting topic and by far the most
common word that comes into it is one
I've already mentioned starting with G
being of course a generic with other
common script is used being basic
standard run-of-the-mill
plain elementary and like a vanilla
milkshake with the argument being that
why would you ever buy a vanilla
milkshake if chocolate strawberry or
dare I say even caramel was available in
discounting the rare and insane
possibility that vanilla is your
favorite flavor this argument does make
some degree of sense but I want you to
remember this rambling milkshake
metaphor because it will return and it
will be relevant but firstly I also want
to address the idea that generic is not
actually intended to be a negative word
it's just evolved that way over time
it's more a term that you would apply to
something that gets the job done to a
satisfactory standard so I just want to
say right at the outset if generic is
the worst thing that one can say about
my hero academia then we are starting
out in a pretty good place because there
are an extraordinary slew of examples of
other shown in series out there that
don't even meet that basic criteria as
for my personal feelings on the matter I
honestly understand the arguments that
people tend to make in regards to my
hero academia being generic and I do
agree with a lot of them now where
I do believe that there is a lot in this
series that does elevate it from vanilla
status and as for everything else that
is very stock standard well it doesn't
exactly hurt the series because if
anything sticking to an established
formula helps to provide it with a solid
foundation to work with the only problem
being when many many other series use
that exact same foundation well then one
can begin to get a bit bored with a lot
of the offerings on the narrative plate
of my hero academia but let's get into
the reasoning as to why many people
choose to place my hero academia in the
G zone and well we have a lot that we
can tick off the Shonan checklist
firstly a plain-looking main protagonist
designed to be a vessel for people to
insert themselves into the fantasy of
the world and live vicariously now this
is one of the things that does annoy me
most about the Shonan genre which is its
tendency to create as plain as possible
of a protagonist in order to keep them
relatable to the bulk of readers and
watched of the series and off the top of
my head someone like sooner from reborn
would fit this bill rather well he's a
basic kid who gets thrust into a crazy
mafia world and the fact that he is
effectively a blank slate allows us to
identify with him very easily and that
is an important gateway into an insane
set of circumstances and personally I
tend to prefer protagonists with a very
clear sense of character which can be
found in a variety of substrates such as
a loud mouthed idiot which you could
find in characters like Luffy or Naruto
you know individuals who demand that
they carve their own space in the series
and I think the temptation is to see is
oku as the plain main character vessel
with very little else to him although I
do very much disagree because Iizuka
does have one crowning trait that
endlessly endears him to me
being his beyond profound drive and a
lot of people are probably going to say
now that well that's just ever shirin
protagonists they all have superhuman
Drive to achieve their goals but he's a
COO actually takes this a huge step
further than most willing to destroy his
body on a regular basis as well as
looses life and even give up on his
dream which as we know in Shonen is far
worse than losing a life to perform
relatively minor actions such as saving
the life of a single child he pretty
perfectly personifies the idealistic
here our mindset and I'll admit that
yeah that might be a bit boring to
explore in a whole host of other series
but when the entire premise is an
exploration of what makes and breaks a
hero then it works pretty damn well so
yes Zuko is a bit plain and a bit
predictable but charming and compelling
nonetheless and works very well within
the context of this particular series
but why else is a series called generic
well let's turn to a point now that I
wholeheartedly agree with which is the
story of my hero academia there is
nothing special about the grace
narrative and that is a problem in my
opinion almost exclusively caused by the
fact that it takes place in a high
school which in and of itself is a very
chirpy premise that adds a fair chunk to
the feeling of being generic because the
issue with centering a series in a
school or I guess any location really is
that it becomes a passive narrative
where the author needs to keep finding
excuses for conflict rather than having
it developed naturally so in the case of
my hero academia conflict can really
only occur under two conditions one is
that the villain attacks the school or a
villain attacks the student while
they're doing some sort of training
outside of school and no that's not the
case 100% of the time because there are
circumstances like the operation against
overhaul where groups come together to
strategically strike a villain but the
overall impression remains regardless it
is such a difficult thing to overcome
and my hero academia ends up rating like
every shown in series you've ever seen
within a school environment and
furthermore because we're specifically
dealing with students there is a big
impetus in place to not have them
develop too much because there just
isn't a lot of room for great
exploration with them and that's because
there are two constants that must remain
in place at all time the students have
to be located at UA and they have to
remain in experienced enough to justify
them being students to begin with and
not only that but they also kept in
their first year because having them
graduate would disturb the status quo
too much however I will say that under
this extremely restrictive framework my
hero academia does a nice amount to
focus on personal growth within the
students and not just use a quiet upper
class 1-a in general have by and large
evolved quite a bit and displayed a nice
sense of depth it certainly isn't the
most spectacular of writing and
characterization available in Shonen let
alone other genres but it is much higher
than a possible grade and for some
comparison and possible grade under
these circumstances is what I would
classify is something like food wars it
suffers from the exact same passive
narrative school setting except that its
characters become almost entirely
stagnant apart from a few key members of
the main cast so thankfully my hero
academia does not do that but to
conclude this point my hero academia
does suffer pretty heavily from its
setting which imposes an incredible
array of narrative restrictions that we
as an audience are very very familiar
with seeing in this day and age so it
certainly does slip into the realm of
generic from a storytelling perspective
and as for something else that often
gets cited as a g-spot
let's talk about villains and this is
another area that I think is much more
nuanced than some would like to think
and yes it is undeniable that there are
so
the flat villains in the series
especially in the early stages but also
particularly in regards to anything
normal related I don't know how to put
this any other way no moves are just
boring even the intelligent ones they
are hulking masses of power that exists
to service slaves to others and as such
it's incredibly hard to generate any
proper trauma from engaging in conflict
with them and that's because for
anything meaningful to come out of a
fight both parties need to have an
investment in what they're doing and
numbers never have any personal
investment in anything they're doing
they are mindless punching machines and
maybe that's okay to do once maybe even
twice if you're feeling bold but to have
them keep coming back into the series is
just a bit and thankfully my hero
academia does have a rather large
selection of antagonists that present a
scale of depth equal to and in many
cases greater than that of our heroes
and the obvious example to this is
always going to be stayin who comes
equipped with an incredible philosophy
of actually believing that the entire
concept of Heroes has been twisted over
time into a money-making industry rather
than people fighting for the sake of
justice or whatnot and I really love
stains take on the world because it's
actually quite a terrifying reflection
of our in reality you know just replaced
heroes with anyone in a leadership
position be a politician sporting role
models etc and you can really have quite
a stock one-to-one representation of our
world but honestly as much they believe
that stain is probably the best example
of the depth filled villain my mind
always goes back to twice who has such a
tragically compelling story behind him
whereby he made so many clones of
himself to do his bidding to the point
where the clones became rather
dissatisfied and started killing one
another until only a single entity
remained who doesn't even know if they
are a clone or the original and as such
twice becomes a brilliant exploration of
identity and what it means to actually
understand who you are or in fact to be
unable to do so
but even villains without these kind of
backstories and ideas do thrive in my
hero academia in fact the entire league
of villains are very captivating figures
to me anyway and command a really solid
presence in the series although on the
flip side what I will say is that the
leading figures amongst villains do tend
to be a bit more of a letdown like
shekhar aki or all-4-one I mean shaker
Aki does have a necessary back story to
explain why he is how he is but for
whatever reason it's just known as
emotionally engaging as most of the sub
villains and all for one is very much
the epitome of evil for the sake of evil
which I guess does kind of need to exist
has an opposing force to the ultimate
good inaccurate based story but it does
that he is a phallus interesting
presence as a result which is a shame
yes but anybody who makes a blanket
statement that the villains of my hero
academia a trash are just plain wrong
there are some that is certainly very
very lacking but there are also others
who present a narrative feast to consume
and become far stronger characters than
the large majority of our protagonists
and I think that gives us a nice general
overview of why my hero academia is
often labeled as generic and some of
that is very hard to argue with in fact
a lot of it I do agree with the serious
has a very very standard narrative
setting the main protagonist is at least
on some level designed to be a blank
slate and the surrounding heroes and
villains are a mixed bag which can
sometimes yes present you with a
flavorless meal and all of these factors
thrown together can make for a very
predictable experience which is why the
term generic gets applied when going
through my hero academia because many
can feel like they've seen this whole
thing before just not with these
specific characters and you can argue
against all of those points which is
fine but even if we took all of that for
granted I want to pose you the question
of is there anything wrong with being
generic and I would personally say that
no there isn't there is absolutely
nothing wrong with the series being
competent in every single area of
storytelling there isn't anything that I
would say my hero academia gets flat-out
wrong and as a result it is a very
enjoyable experience even if it doesn't
offer anything wildly groundbreaking I
genuinely love my hero academia and I am
a snob I studied design for theater in
university which spent three whole years
teaching me how to critically analyze
and deconstruct every element of
storytelling which means that when I say
something subpar I will go absolutely
off at it but when I see something that
does work it's very difficult to judge
it for actually working so yeah there
are things I'd like to see more of but
my hero academia is able to stand on its
own two legs and perhaps yes so his legs
are spawned from a legacy of series
preceding it but it's still and
undeniably solid series and from there
the only problem I can see is that of
fans over rating the series which yes is
certainly a problem one that does born
from the anime adaptation which honestly
given the source material is pretty damn
spectacular and a ton of credit
obviously needs to go straight to the
music which brings this world to life
but the animation is also generally
great as are the vocal performances and
all the rounds this is everything that I
would want an anime adaptation to be
however when you take a great adaptation
and start claiming that the series
itself is one of the best things ever
created
because that may be your personal
impression and I'm not judging you for
thinking that you know am I here
academia has some really hard-hitting
moments especially in the anime but to
others who then read or watch the series
with overwhelming expectations placed on
it then they are naturally going to be
disappointed potentially even to the
point of anger thinking that they were
sold an empty bill of goods so that's
something to be wary of and not just
with my hero academia but with every
piece of media is my hero academia a
generic Shonen format thing oh yeah it
certainly is does it have its aspects
where it rises above generis ism yes it
most certainly does and even if it
didn't does being generic mean you
shouldn't enjoy it for what it is it
most certainly does not
if you'd rather spend your time watching
or reading something else something that
presents you with new and challenging
ideas and formats to consume then I
completely understand that we are human
beings and we are constantly in search
of new stimuli but I will never actively
throw hate onto a series that does
everything to a competent level let
alone one that does surpass that in many
aspects so as much as it's not my
favorite thing in the world my hero
academia is just fun to be involved with
and to any fans who get annoyed when
people sometimes call this series
generic just remember the what they're
actually saying is my hero academia is a
well-rounded series that does everything
right but it's just not enough for me
personally and really if being generic
is the worst thing that people can say
about it then that is actually a pretty
damn stunning endorsement of this series
just remember there is a very good
reason why restaurants and other
assorted food dispensaries don't just
offer chocolate and strawberry
milkshakes and that's because generic
owner vanilla is the absolute foundation
of milkshakes it does everything right
but some people just want a bit more
flavor that doesn't mean the vanilla
isn't superb there but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more anime content then please do
check out some of my other videos we'll
even subscribe to the channel for
potential regular my hero academia Wanda
delivered straight to your YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time